okay help me
okay
okay uh my name is chipotle i'm
a new quantum portfolio and today i'll
be uh talking about unclondable
cryptography
so uh as also introduced by andrea
in this talk we will also leverage the
quantum nuclear in principle well
basically it says uh there's no way
for a quantum algorithm to copy unknown
quantum state
classically it is simple because you
know like every single bit and you can
simply write the bit twice and you can
copy a quantum stick but this is not
doable in a quantum set
so
the no cloning principle opens the door
to many classically impossible
cryptography primitives this example
includes like the famous quantum key uh
distribution
by bernard and brazard and quantum money
first proposed by wizner back in 60s and
later published in 83
and also like like quantum copy
protection first proposed by erisan and
there are many many more applications
and this application relies on some
forms of uh
unclonability of certain quantum states
and namely
there are some famous examples for
example the
bb-84 states or the the wizner states
there are like many examples using this
state or
the subspace states
and more recently we uh with andrea and
other colleges we give a
a unified notion a generalized notion
called a coset states which possess many
important properties of both bb-84
states and
subspace states
so
in this talk
i will briefly talk about these
unclonable states but not
give any implications of copy protection
but just use a
maybe the simplest example which called
position verification
so
and we will see like uh what's the
difference between different unclonable
states just by looking at their
implementation of position verification
so position verification is a protocol
to verify one's location in a in a
cryptographic way
and let's look at position verification
in a 1d dimensional space
so we have two verifiers at the end of
the one-dimensional space and there's an
astronaut which we said it's like
approver
wants to claim it is at certain location
of the space
and then in this example we say
for convenience the astronaut claims it
is at a location 0.5 which is in the
middle of the space
okay so
and we want to have a protocol to to
verify its exact location so the first
thought is by simply doing so called
distance bonding
so instead of proving the astronaut is
at a certain location
we can first try to prove it is within
certain distance of the verifier and
this is actually a very easy we don't
need any cryptographic tool or any
quantum information we can simply add a
verifier
one verifier send a random message and
broadcast the message
and later on it uh wants to receive the
message back
on time
so because we know that there's no
faster than light communication if it
received the message on let's say time
one then the astronaut must lie in the
in the uh
within like 0.5 of the verifier
so this proves uh the astronaut within
certain distance of the verifier
therefore it's natural to maybe
let's say uh we can put another verifier
on the right of the of the space and
both of them do distance bonding and
then we can claim the astronaut is
exactly at 0.5
but however this
are some problems with this protocol
um look at this example well instead of
have one uh astronaut now we have two
malicious astronauts they are having
some uh clothing strategy
so i will see that uh in this example
there are two uh astronauts one sits in
their point three and the the other one
sits in 0.7
so
they can just handle the uh the queries
uh for the left one you can handle the
query from the left verifier and
similarly for the right astronaut so
actually in general uh
uh we can show that any classical
protocol cannot be secure in other words
if uh everything is uh uh like the
communication and the computation are
both purely classical then there's no
secure
position verification protocol
so
therefore it's natural to think about
maybe we can exchange quantum
information like using some unclonable
quantum states and because we will see
um
we see that in the in the impossibility
result the attack comes from we can copy
classical information but here using
quantum information maybe we can prevent
the attack
so
now uh
this is like we first introduced the
most fundamental state which process
which poses some some forms of unclean
ability
which are bb-84 states so uh since
andrea already explained that i will
just uh quickly go through it so
basically uh these are two sets of
non-orthogonal states well theta
indicates uh the basis if c is zero
we're in the computational basis and if
there is one we're in the hardware basis
they can be either a zero state of one
state or a plastic or a minor state
and we usually use uh xceta to denote a
sequence of bb-84 states so
in this example x can be 0 1 0 and see
that can be
1.0
and they can encode a bunch of uh bb-84
states let's say uh enquiry
and the bb-84 states uh have the
following on chronobility which is
first proved as so-called monogamy of
entanglement
but where we just say uh we just view it
as an unclonability so the game says um
if we uh if the challenger give or know
bb-84 states to a quantum algorithm
there's no way for the quantum algorithm
to split the quantum state into two
copies
and later on this uh this two quantum
machine upon giving these copies they
cannot communicate with each other and
then
uh
they they then get the the basis
information which help them to uh
extract the secret which is the x
and they show that it is actually very
hard for even unbounded quantum
adversaries to both simultaneously
extract the info the secret x and
this is the uh on the like the hardness
of unclonability
so uh with the help of the v846 we can
then show uh
how to do position verification in a
perfect secure way without using any uh
hardware assumptions
so
uh to do that we simply send a db 84
states from the left verifier which is
the quantum verifier and for the right
verify it sends the basis information
theta which helps
the astronaut to recover the secret x
and when these two information meets in
the middle the the astronaut can try to
uh extract x and then broadcast x to
both the quantum verifier and the
classical verifier
okay
so next we show that with the help of
unknown ability the scheme is actually
secure
so at example uh
let's consider two malicious uh
astronauts which they're not in the
middle of the of the space
then
uh they receive either exita or the
basis information theorem
and without loss of
generality the astronaut on the left can
try to copy the state and prepare row
one and row two it will keep row one and
send row two to the other astronaut and
the right astronaut because it receives
classical information which is the
description of the basis
it can simply forward that basis so it
ends up with a following setting well
there are two non-local astronauts they
cannot communicate because they're far
away from each other they cannot uh
therefore they don't have enough time to
communicate but
they have like uh row one
uh quantum state with the basis
information theta and for the right one
they have row two and also theta and to
uh to convince the verifier they need to
both learn x which exactly reduce to the
unclonable gain in other words if they
can break or if they can uh fool the
verifier they must break the unknown
ability of the bb-84 states
so we have seen a physician verification
scheme
however there are some drawbacks of the
this
of the scheme first is it is hard to
authenticate a quantum state therefore
there might be some malicious verifier
uh they want to try to uh steal the
location
the information of the location of the
astronaut
and the second is the problem that
transmitting quantum message as we see
we need to send a bb-84 states it is
actually very expensive and has high
rate of arrow
so we want this whole protocol to be a
fault tolerance
so therefore we solve the first problem
by using closed states which
provides some kind of public
verifiability which bb-84 says does not
have
and second was solve the
problem of uh fault tolerant by making
only classical communication that is we
we force the position verification to
just exchange classical communications
and because classical communications are
cheap and easy to be fault tolerant we
solve the second problem
so let's uh
look at how to solve the first problem
the impossibility of classical
information and classical communication
and in the in the second way of solving
the problem we use classical
communication and quantum
classical communication and quantum
communication like global quantum
navigation yeah exactly exactly
yeah yeah sure
okay so uh yeah for the first problem we
use some something called closed estates
here i'm i'm not going to uh talk about
this uh in details but basically as we
see the unclonability of vb-84 states
um
here we we have a subspace a where this
a is basically the the the basis
information theta and uh we have s and s
prime you can think about this is just
like the x in the in the bb 84 states so
this exactly the same as uh
unclonability of the 84 states but it
has some extra uh extra advantage that
uh
even if you provide these two uh uh
program the program can help you to
do uh authenticate that is if the
quantum state pass both programs there
are a classical program then we can
assure that the quantum state is a
particular state
so it's provide another way to
authenticate the quantum state and the
unknown ability host even if we're
giving this to authentication program
so uh this is like the only difference
between bb-8 for uncle mobility and
this coset states
so therefore
we can easily transit position
verification
and we make it uh
with authentication so simply instead of
sending bb-84 states we set closest
states and we send the basis information
and finally they want to extract the
secret which is s and s prime
so to authenticate we can first
authenticate all the classical
information which is the classical
program there's two programs and the
basis information
and then we can authenticate the the
quantum state using these two programs
so it's provide an easy way to
authenticate the whole protocol
and finally we show how to make it fall
tolerant so we make it fault tolerant by
using a different method based on noisy
chapter property functions which are
used for proof of quantumness and
certifiable randomness
so we will not go into any details of
ntcfs but we prove that based on ntcefs
there's a following on clone ability
with only classical communication so uh
the challenger only make classical
interaction with the player and at the
end of the game the player will have
some unknown but also on cloneable
states and later on the the player want
to copy the state into two parts
and and
similarly these two parts cannot
communicate with each other
and then these two parts of the quantum
algorithm will later on receive this
identical but random challenges
and they cannot produce valid answers
corresponding to these same challenges
okay
so
and based on that we can achieve a
position verification protocol with
purely classical verifier but only the
local uh
like the prover which is the astronaut
need to be quantum
okay so to conclude we use uh the
position verification scheme as an
example and show some different
unclonability so there are actually many
more applications than position
verification
i think it's an active area and would
have many interesting implications in
both quantum information and
cryptography
so
that's concluded my talk thanks
i'm actually really confused by this
model like i don't understand how it's
possible if you go for more than two
dimensions like how do i even transmit
like a quantum state like in all three
dimensions like it seems like that would
violate no cloning oh so yeah so you
cannot like broadcast from
messages
the first is like maybe you can send
directional messages or you can use
entanglement but like that's exactly the
point well um
like in the last example we use
classical communications
because if it gives you that direction
then you have to know where they are
before you even verify them yes exactly
exactly yes yeah that's actually yeah
that's a very good question so that's
another motivation for considering uh
purely classical communications and also
it seems like the classical possibility
that only applies the fixed uh verifier
location right the verifiers chose their
locations randomly independent of the
grouper i don't think that a possibility
would apply
oh it sounds like an easier way than
having not necessarily all right i mean
as long as you have like polynomial or
like
many many many adversaries no longer
they are not in the exact location
uh the impossibility would apply i
believe
we can talk about software okay
that's great
so let's thank all the speakers